die nachricht des tages aus deutscher
sicht ist die kehrtwende
deutschland will 400 panzerfäuste in die
ukraine liefern allerdings nicht direkt
sondern über bande sozusagen über die
niederlande genau thomas so ist es ist
es eine 180 grad kehrtwende der
bundesregierung eine kehrtwende die ich
absolut begrüße denn unsere freiheit
wird gerade in kiew verteidigt wenn der
westen jetzt nicht eingreift dann wird
es so sein dass die weltpolitik künftig
von russland und china geschrieben wird
china schaut gerade sehr interessiert zu
die deutsche außenministerin wohl china
sagte annalena baerbock hat mit ihrem
chinesischen amtskollegen wang heute
telefoniert hat auch noch einmal
gefordert dort druck zu machen von
chinesischer seite aber es sind ja die
deutschen die selber möglichkeiten haben
und die sie jetzt in dieser hinsicht
zumindest wahrnehmen das andere was ein
bisschen peinlich war heute für
deutschland muss man sagen dass der
polnische ministerpräsident hierher
gekommen ist und noch mal druck gemacht
hat deutschland egoismus vorgeworfen hat
weil deutschland das land war dass sich
vor allem dagegen gestellt hatte diesen
zahlungsverkehr diesen internationalen
ebenen nicht abzusprechen thomas der
auftritt unseres polnischen gastes heute
hat mich sehr gerührt er hat sinngemäß
gesagt dass durch die gaspipelines nicht
nur gas fließt sondern auch das blut
ukrainische kinder und menschen das ist
ein vorwurf den sich deutschland
wirklich hat machen müssen und ich will
ehrlich mit dir sein ich saß bereits von
einem schriftlichen kommentar heute für
die bild -zeitung der nächsten tage in
dem ich geschrieben habe ich schäme mich
gerade für dieses land weil wir ja
eigentlich aus unserer historischen
verantwortung heraus hätten lernen
müssen frieden schaffen ohne waffen ist
ein hehres ziel ist ein schöner slogan
aber die geschichte unsere eigene
geschichte lehrt uns doch dass das eben
nur ganz selten der fall ist in der
regel muss frieden wenn ein aggressor
wie putin dabei ist eben mit
waffengewalt geschaffen werden und
deswegen noch mal ganz kurz zu den
panzerfäusten sie sind ja in den
niederlanden das heißt dass deutschland
hier im moment eigentlich nur macht ist
den niederlanden die erlaubnis zu geben
die panzerfäuste in ein drittland zu
exportieren da war deutschland bislang
immer sehr restriktiv
mit dem export von in deutschland her
gelangt hergestellten waffen durch ein
weiteres land das hat sich jetzt sehr
übrig und es ist für deutschland schon
relativ spektakulär es ist noch nicht so
viel wie dass wir eigene deutsche waffen
selbst dorthin liefern ein schritt den
ich persönlich auch begrüßen würde aber
ist spektakulär weil diese
panzerfäuste erstens wirklich helfen
können sie sind einfach zu bedienen ist
das ist eine standardwaffe die sehr weit
eingesetzt wird sie funktionieren gut
und zweitens aber auch weil auch noch
andere länder deutsche waffen haben die
sie eigentlich gerne in die ukraine
exportieren würden und es besteht
durchaus hoffnung dass der erste
dominostein jetzt gefallen ist so dass
zb estland wo deutsche haubitzen
vorhanden sind möglicherweise auch
künftig diese haubitzen nach in die
ukraine exportieren darüber dass jetzt
in diesem zeitraum wo wir sehen der
russische vormarsch geschieht eben nicht
ganz so schnell wie befürchtet und die
ukraine wahnsinnig mutige leute denen
ich wirklich nur meinen größten respekt
aussprechen kann kämpfen und kämpfen und
kämpfen selbst zivilisten in diesem
kurzen zeitraum der sich jetzt gerade
öffnet waffen zu liefern ist glaube ich
eindeutig der richtige schritt um klar
zu machen auch der westen hat noch etwas
zu sagen bis hierhin und nicht weiter
gebaut dramatischer appelle heute unter
anderem von wladimir klitschko dem
bruder von vitali klitschko dem
bürgermeister von kiew der noch mal
ausdrücklich betont hat es geht um jede
stunde morgen kann es zu spät sein jetzt
muss gehandelt werden und nicht mehr
lange gezögert und bedacht und
nachgedacht werden es geht um jede
stunde die bilder die ich jetzt auch
immer wieder gesehen habe bei unserem
faktencheck hat ihm dass er sich alle
videos aus den sozialen medien anschaut
um zu überprüfen damit bild hier keine
oder möglichst wenig fehler macht die
waren wirklich beeindruckend das sind
zivilisten die aus diesen großen waffen
kisten sich einfach automatische waffen
nehmen und die dann den krieg ziehen
menschen wie man muss das so sagen du
und ich die einen tag zwei tage vorher
noch ein vollkommen anderes leben hatten
ehe dieser abnormalität der russischen
provokation in ihr leben eingebrochen
ist und stell dir vor in diesen waffen
kiste je mehr waffen dort drin sind je
mehr munition da drin ist umso größer
wird die chance dass den großen hier
wirklich noch mal verluste zugefügt
werden können es kursieren auch bereits
einige fotos von festgenommenen russen
von fest gesetzten russin
die ihr von denen man auch dem anschein
nach zumindest teilweise den eindruck
haben kann manche dieser russischen
soldaten wollen gar nicht kämpfen sie
sind von putin in einen konflikt
geschickt worden mit dem zumindest
einige der soldaten man kann sicher
nicht für alle sprechen gar nichts zu
tun haben wollen und gleichzeitig für
mich fast ebenso beeindruckend in
russland selbst wächst der widerstand
gegen die politik des tyrannen darf man
glaube ich mittlerweile sagen das tor an
wladimir putin und auch ruß den den
russen noch mal zu signalisieren der
westen hat hier wirklich was dagegen
auch deutschland hat was gegen diesen
krieg ist glaube ich unheimlich wichtig
und ich bin froh dass die
bundesregierung nun endlich anfängt sich
auch anderen ländern die längst
waffenexporte zu lassen anzuschließen
sondern sind wir in deutschland ja eher
friedensbewegte als kriegs bewegte aus
gutem grunde natürlich aus unserer
geschichte heraus trotzdem war die
position ja auch nicht mehr haltbar denn
wir liefern einerseits waffen an
autokratische länder wie ägypten
beispielsweise oder wie saudi arabien
haben keine probleme damit aber dann
wenn es in europa um einen
demokratischen staat geht der ums
überleben kämpfte haben wir gezögert ja
thomas hast du vollkommen recht und
natürlich wie jeder mensch glaube ich
wie jeder normale mensch sind ja auch du
und ich der meinung kein krieg wäre am
besten keine aggression wäre am besten
aber die geschichte zeigt eben dass
leute die so aggressiv vorgehen wie es
vladimir putin tut nur auf eine art der
ansprache reagieren nämlich auf ein
hartes so geht das nicht weiter und er
hat ja nun auch ganz klar gemacht er
sieht die sowjetunion als sein großes
vorbild das impliziert auch dass nach
der ukraine die nächsten länder dran
sind die womöglich 1 zur sowjetunion
gehört haben und deswegen sind wir
leider leider in eine situation geraten
in der es nun wirklich hart auf hart
geht und natürliches augenmaß gefragt
natürlich muss der frieden das
ultimative ziel bleiben aber jetzt
zunächst mal zu sagen moment
weltgeschichte wird nicht ohne das
einverständnis des westens geschrieben
ist glaube ich ein sehr sehr wichtiges
signal auch für die ganze welt und tor
selber darauf hingewiesen dass wir in
ganz andere länder waffen exportieren
was sich äußerst kritisch sehe aber wenn
du auch noch an die jüngere
vergangenheit denkst unsere freiheit
wird am hindukusch verteidigt unsere
freiheit wird bei anti piraten einsätzen
vor der somalischen küste verteidigt das
mag alles sein oder auch nicht ich
möchte diese fälle jetzt hier gar nicht
bewerten aber wenn wir daran geglaubt
haben als bundesregierung als land dann
müssen wir doch ganz klar anerkennen
dass unsere freiheit weit mehr weit
stärker jetzt in kiew verteidigt wird
und dann dürfen wir leider nicht
zurückschrecken es kann auch sein dass
ich so eine welle der solidarität des
zusammenhalts entwickelt die putin
tatsächlich beeindrucken könnte die
grenzen aufzeigen könnte dass uns das
noch einmal ganz kurz über dieses
vermeintlich so komplizierte swift reden
diese entscheidung die da auch
bevorsteht die eu scheint sich relativ
einig zu sein es könnte bald passieren
dass also russland auch auf druck der
amerikaner in russland von diesem
internationalen zahlungssystemen
ausgeschlossen wird das bedeutet und ich
glaube das müssen wir unseren zuschauern
also den bürgern in deutschland auch
sagen dass das auch konsequenzen für uns
haben kann weil beispielsweise wir
unsere gaslieferungen nicht mehr
bezahlen können was bedeutet dass wir
womöglich auch kein gas mehr bekommen
können thomas das ist wahr alles was du
sagst stimmt und das ist bitter und es
ist bitter für die deutschen bürger
trotzdem bin ich für swift sanktionen
und bin dafür die russen von swift zu
trennen denn putin ich habe das nun
schon mehrfach gesagt versteht meines
erachtens nach nur eine sprache und zwar
eine sprache der härte ich weiß dass es
da negative nebeneffekte gibt es gibt ja
auch immer diese debatte dann baut
russland eben ein eigenes
zahlungssystemen baut es womöglich mit
china zusammen es gibt wieder ein
verstärktes blockdenken das sehe ich
alles mit allergrößter sorge und das
sind argumente die man abwägen muss
ebenso natürlich wie könnten die
heizkosten für die deutschen wirklich
explodieren nicht nur das was angela
merkel mit ihrer abkehr von der
atomkraft bislang angerichtet hat die
enormen preissteigerungen in den letzten
wochen sondern könnten sie nun wirklich
ex studieren wenn wir die swift
sanktionen in kraft setzen und damit
dann mehr oder weniger auch auf
russisches gas verzichten ja das ist so
und hier erwarte ich von der
bundesregierung eben auch eine sehr
schnelle gesetzgebung dass die ärmeren
deutschen nicht im kalten sitzen werden
sondern dass man wie ein soli vielleicht
eine art der besteuerung schafft und
sagt okay das ist nun wirklich geld das
wir nehmen um die heizkosten
auszugleichen für manche leute nicht
mehr bezahlbar werden sein oder über
manche leute eben sehr sehr schwierig
nur noch zu bezahlen sind aber müssten
wir nicht mit unserer historischen
vergangenheit auch bescheid auch bereit
sein eine solche schwierigkeit auf uns
zu nehmen wenn wir gleichzeitig sehen
wie die ukraine mit dem leben ihrer
söhne und ihre männer und zunehmend
leider auch ihrer frauen und ihre kinder
das eigene land verteidigen um einen
aggressor der uns deutsche ganz klar
bedroht zu stoppen